what we're doing Isaac today we are
doing what we're we are building my new
beau Fork
all right so we have Isaac for the
weekend which is rare it is really rare
that we have 90 for the weekend he's
always at his dad's house but since we
have them there's a change that he's
been wanting in his room which is
expanding his clubhouse so originally
this used to be your bedroom you can
sleep in here and your bed was in here
right so now you're moving your bed back
up to the top and you want it to have
some walls here to protect you mm-hmm
make you feel cozy your blueprints
blueprints the bird's eye view in the
aerial view I think you're the architect
huh and then mommy's the contractor and
the contractor mama the contract yeah
baby yeah she's helping me build this
painting her about a million dollars
you're a million dollars I think what
day something like I'm paying her with
love or something oh yeah a million
dollars oh I want to work hire me hired
me I paint here with love
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what did you call this again what's this
called the battle the battlefield base
for some battlefield base welcome to my
room
and today we made my whole room into
this little Clubhouse so I'm gonna be
giving you guys a tour up there's where
you sleeping right is where the magic
happens the magic what kind of magic
magic the magic where you read this is
packed so if you going here here knows
right here
Oh cute he's ready there he's my in my
guard to my guard he's my lion guard
he's your lion guard oh he left
quick get on his break yeah so over here
is where my board games are DVDs other
stuff like this flashlight which is kind
of cool cuz that's how I got the name
for the battlefield face oh because of
the game battleship yeah backwards yeah
go back oh would be the only for kids
not for Georgia okay so over here is a
chair where I can sit on this for fun
sometimes
so over here what do we have here so
this is a door I like to call the
electric door pardon electric door yes
so how do get it is you need a place I'm
enjoy it reaches to sixty like right so
it's one right wherever it open the door
yeah ah oh you forgot oh you can open
the door then
I can't this might take a while put it
put it in fast motion like it's gonna go
friends like okay oh yeah
again well well well
so over here is where I put all my
electric stuff more that plug into here
is for my fan through the light and this
is for the lights over there so which I
come back over here lock it you unlocked
it over here low Reading area have Harry
Potter I just finished the book so I
might bring it up here soon this is for
like I came late down and read and then
over here is another area where I want
to get comfortable
mmm so it's like I have a vine by a
friend
anyone I just sit hero's there it could
be like all right I'll write yourself up
I'll lay over here oh you're real here
all right I'll go here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just put that right here right awfully
outfit you're done with it
what a relief good why does he not fit
move on to the next thing
oh look who's coming down from
construction the construction is done it
takes a long time yeah this is not meant
for adults escape when you need a better
exit strategy luckily you didn't go out
through the main entrance what's the
main end right there that's the main
tunnel
yeah the tunnel this is effects yeah so
come up here mm-hmm
my second story as you remember if you
guys know more my Legos are smooth guys
now this is a good guys either and their
cars so up here if you come up here up
here is my room we put cardboard I never
actually got to sleep up here now you're
a parrot
yeah yeah right your breath climbing
there's own Clubhouse you move your face
up so you can see your mouth make eye
contact
so over here I think I might tape this
right here to see all the intruders
right now computers and now cue the epic
music now wars about
[Applause]
[Music]
you got your books back yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
why
[Music]
all right so we had a really relaxing
day today didn't do anything other than
build the for play in the floor tickle
fight and then I went forward for
shopping and now I cooked I have shrimps
scraps are just for me cuz neither one
of you guys think scraps I do I like oh
I just work so much is no no I don't
feel like one day they're gonna discover
that you like script niblet oh my
goodness I've been missing out for 20
years of my life a lot of my friends I
didn't like shrimp or seafood 20 years
old that's when they're like sushi oh my
goodness
anyways I got sweet potatoes as well and
I'm trying to get off the rice and I
knew too much for rice corn must-have
for barbecues yeah this thing we picked
up in Italy during our trip in Italy so
did you do it they cute up off the top
of it and then you kind of squeeze the
lemon everywhere pour the jus you can't
have corn without the yum eat that
cheese and then you just kind of
sprinkle that what Oh
you're torturing me looks I'm good and
then because broccoli
[Music]
we got [ __ ] going what song that dude in
the background you can see your swimming
trunks over there looks like your
opinion your underwear one now the water
is saying I got thinking all over the
place you put this in a different way
what do we do you want to explain to
them what tiny is oh yeah some people
always ask me what is it
what would you explain that up Tae Hee
Tae Hee is a little thing like spring or
what do you call it but spices now you
put kind of like salt in basically a mix
of salt and like spicy stuff like really
stuff and they also have some like my
niece's yeah and there's just like a
fire that means it's just a little bit
like he's not really feeling my mouth is
exploding because this looks so
delicious
[Music]